let me ask you questions so all you all
of you have been uh
you were a comedian you tried in
colorado you stepped one to business
you're still comedian and you're
obviously still uh
performing as well so
what is the difference between today
because you've been in it uh
90s 2000 2010s now 2020s like i think
about a justin bieber right how the guy
found justin bieber usher's sister's
like oh look at this guy okay oh my god
this guy's kid's playing sydney you know
all that was pretty sick what if there
was no uber could would we have a justin
bieber that we have today i don't know
you see how uh uh uh back in the days
the uh the the what is the group uh
don't stop believing that's what is that
journey they find a filipino guy that
comes and becomes a lead so
has it when you see some guys like is
there a lot of stories of people that
just pop up and oh they're they chose to
become a comedian they got a big
following year and a half later they're
comedians they're getting specials is
that what's happening today or was that
not the way it was 20 30 years ago i i
it's a very good question you know when
i came up there was no social media
so you were always
thrown into a room and it was in boston
it was in new york it was in kansas it
was in la it was in bakersfield wherever
it was idaho was random now here was the
difference they were strangers who
didn't know you and oh by the way they
didn't share a common sense ability i
can do stand-up now in mumbai or bombay
and they're going to get the jokes that
they get in los angeles because the
internet has brought us together we
there is this sort of collective
consciousness this neural net if you
will that we all tap into not so coming
up so most of my career most of bill
burr's rogans all of the older guys
were were we
came up in boston pittsburgh with a
bunch of working-class dudes going i
don't know you i work for a living make
me laugh
and it got quiet quick if you didn't
bring the money if you didn't bring the
money and you were doing your esoteric
stuff that's so good if you were up in
canada and then you came down to miami i
promise you it's a different group and
if you're up there doing your stuff now
now what's happened is you can curate
your own audience
you have people that have been listening
to you on a podcast forever so you have
your fans are there and they're they're
it's like your family they're already
laughing because they just want to have
an experience with you
but the pressure is not the same so so
i think in many ways i'll take heat for
this but i think in many ways that's not
so good for comedy i agree with you 100
it's deluded because now i think i told
patrick earlier if you just make a tick
tock video and you have you know
millions of followers like you said
they'll come watch you they'll pay the
ticket you'll fill up a theater yes and
it's not it's deluded comic to me but
this is me don't i'm not and i hate when
people go oh you're hating or the hustle
i didn't i didn't say none of that [ __ ]
what i'm saying is
he came up before me but like you have
to go to these rooms and you have to
feel like it was word of mouth like you
became dope because you were talking
about you around the country you did
legacy media right you would go and do
the the radio tour in the morning all of
us did no i don't care who you were yeah
and also nobody was making money you got
to remember that now comics are making
money so so let me ask you you didn't
make money back today
uh uh who is a like a real real og
comedian
even if you were to take out social
media so take out they have no file okay
so bill is one i can listen a bit all
day long sebastian man
we had him on last year at the event he
was freaking amazing dove davidoff
doesn't do comedy as much anymore but a
monster beast you know sam tripoli no he
doesn't you know people don't know what
a monster you can put sam tripoli up
anywhere anytime he'll do an hour and
then do a whole new hour and he can do
the most offensive [ __ ] or the or the
greatest stuff you're he just chooses
you know there are guys like that that
doing nothing but stand up oh sam yeah
but there's so many guys vinnie's
phenomenal have you seen i mean there
are a lot of guys who are just who who
can get up there and crush a room and
anywhere it is so i was if i had known
vinnie was here i know that i could take
vinnie and put him up anywhere in the
country thank you and he's gonna he's
gonna
he's gonna take 30 minutes and crush
that room i can tell you he is because
he came up the right way
so you know
but but any of the old guys rogan you
know joe's joe was doing joe was see
people don't realize this either and
i've known justin i was 28 i'm 27.
joe was
crushing you've never seen anyone and
i'm gonna say you've never seen anyone
crush a room like he did when he was 28
29 30 31 32. he would get up anywhere i
don't care if it was mars
and that dude
he had he had a bit about two tigers
having sex
dude
i can't even it would it would bring the
house down it would bring the house down
he would melt it good luck following him
yeah good luck i don't care who i've saw
the biggest comics in the world try to
follow that it was like oh no no the
oxygen's gone guys the oxygen i watched
him in jacksonville he invited me i went
up there and jax won't listen to him i
felt like i had an ab workout oh yeah i
mean i was like and that's now but back
then he was just doing
now he's trying to say things now it's
like there's a through line there's a
theme back then it was just i'm gonna
i'm gonna that's all we so we would get
up and it was just all it was was i want
to see if i can this is when you knew
you were killing it if you could do an
hour and a 15 minutes
and nobody got up to go to the bathroom
that's right
that for me that was that's my that's
still my barometer like i'm looking i'm
going if i can keep these dudes if i can
kill these guys for that long without
anybody and then then you know you did
your job because when you're done they
stay all wrong no bathroom they don't
want to miss anything that's when you're
doing it right let me ask you so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]